قسم ايراني بصاروخ بالستي ومسير مفخخه
يستهدف مقرات المعارضه الكرديه شمال
العراق
التظاهرات الليليه في مدن ايرانيه
عن قمع المتظاهرين
الوكاله الذريه تجري تقيما لاضرار محطه
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
جديده
الايرانيه في شمال كردستان العراق بعد
ضربات الممثله قبل اقل من اسبوع مراسل
العربيه
في اقليم كردستان العراق وذلك في وقت
اطلقت القنصليه الامريكيه في اربيل
مطار اربيل الدولي ان الرحله الجويه لم
تتاثر بالقصف الايراني
باي باي
[موسيقى]
قال المرصد السوري ان عدد قتلى ضربات
تركيه على شمال سوريا ارتفع الى 35 في وقت
تجدد فيه القصف تركيا للريف الغربي لمدينه
عين العرب التابعه لمحافظه حلب السوريه
حسبنا ذكرت وكاله هواره الكرديه وافادت
مصادر كرديه
ثقيله وقذائف الهاون استهدف بلده شيوخ
فوقاني وقرى محيطه بعد ان استهدف القصف
التركي في وقت سابق مقاطعه الشهباء ومحيط
منطقه عفرين ياتي هذا في ما قالت قوه
سوريا ديمقراطيه ان الهجمات تركيا لا
تستهدف الشعب الكرديه وحده بل جميع مكونات
شمال وشرق سوريا وتوعدت انقر برد قويا
ومؤثر
ما ان عاد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
من اندونيسيا حتى دوره الانفجارته بالعراق
وسوريا مدمره نحو 90 هدفا في قواعد
للمسلحين الاكراد يوم الحساب اتى بكلمتين
وصوره لمقاتله تقلع لتنفيذ غاره ليليه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التركيه عن شنها عمليه
المخلب السيف وبالفعل قصفت الطائره
الحربيه بخمسه وعشرين ضربه قنديل واسوس
وهاكرك في العراق وكباني وتل رفعه وذراك
في شمال سوريا
صدام
وانفاق ومستودعات للمسلحين نسفت ولم يكن
هذا الدمار الا جزء من ضمن 85 مليون من
الاتراك على حد تعبيره
حسبناهم ولن نتوانا عن حسابهم في كل مره
يمس بها استقرار بلادنا هكذا يتابع اثار
قوله لتاخذ تركيا بثارها من مقاتلنا اكراد
ينتمون لحزب العمال الكردستاني غارات قتلت
واصابه العشرات من المدنيين عدا عن فقدان
اخرين بين تلك الانقاذ بحسب ما افاد به
المرصد السوري اما اداره شمال وشرق سوريا
بعد ان اتخذت انقره من حادثه اسطنبول
زريعه للجن عملياتها بدوره حزب العمال
للكردستاني اتهم تركيا بامتلاك خطوط غامضه
واظهار كوباني كهدف تلك المدينه التي تمثل
رمزا لحمايه الاكراد من تنظيم داعش منذ
عكرت اجوائها الطائره التركيه مره رائعه
بدات بعمليه درع الفرات في 2016 ثم بغصن
الزيتون في العام الذي يليه الى نبع
السلام
الى ثلاث سنوات
الصغير العربيه
من تصاعد العنف ضد المتظاهرين في ايران
وخاصه في مدينه مهبود وقال نواشنتن تسعى
الى محاسبه المسؤولين عن العنف وتواصلوا
الدعم الشعبي الايراني
في عدد من المدن الايرانيه منجده بنظام
لاسيا في كرج في حين اضرامه محتاجوننا في
صوره خامنئي في مقبره
زهراء في ظهران
[موسيقى]
قناه
مسلسل
[موسيقى]
في قوه الامن
وكانها سكنه ومسرح مداهمات لا مدينه اعتاد
فيها اكراد ايران على التجوال في مهاباد
تسن قوات الامن الايرانيه حمله اعتقالات
وقمح ضد المحتجين الذين بداوا برفع سقف
المطالب والطموح معها من التحقيق
بالاعتقالات التعسفيه الى الحريه واسقاط
النظام المدينه تشهد حركه عسكره كبيره
وافادت منظمه حقوقيه بان السلطه او فدت
قوات مسلحه الى مهابات من اورميا في
محافظه اذربيجان الغربيه وسط معلومات عن
اطلاق نار
رافقتها فيديوهات متداوله تظهر اقام الامن
الايراني بالطائرات المسيره لاستهداف ورصد
المحتاجين
الايرانيه لم تكتفي بالاعتقالات والقمع
ماتت وفقه تقارير للمعارضه الى هدم منازل
مواطنين في ماهبات بتهم استهداف قوات
الامن
بدوره اشار موقع ايران انترناشونال الى ان
القوات المسلحه تتجول بالسيارات في مهبات
بدون توقف في وقت يصف مواطنون اكراد اجواء
المدينه بانها تشبه اجواء الاحكام العرفيه
[موسيقى]
للكردي نقطه احتجاج جديده تسع السلطات
الايرانيه على مدى الاشهر الثلاثه التي
ثلاث مقتل مهسا اميني الى اخمادها لكن
بدون نجاح يذكر اقله حتى الساعه
قال رئيس الاوكراني
القوات الروسيه الطقس في مواقع اوكرانيا
على الخطوط الاماميه بالمدفعيه وان
المنطقه الشرقيه وحدها تعرضت لما يقرب من
400 ضربه يوم امس الاحد
اقل من الهجمات اليوم بسبب سوء الاحوال
الجويه
الى الامام اثناء القتال وحتى الان وقع ما
يقرب من 400 هجوم مدفعي في الشرق منذ
بدايه امس
وصل الدهنه
فريق تابع للوكاله الدوليه اليوم اجراء
تقييم للاضرار التي لحقت لحقت بمحطه نوويه
والتي تعرضت لقصفين يتبادل الجيشان
الاوكراني وروسيا الاتهامات بقصف المنشاه
الوكاله الدوليه قالت ان هناك اضرار لحيقه
ببعض المباني والانظمه والمعدات في الموقع
لكن ايا منها لا يشكل اي خطوره على
السلامه والامن النوويين حتى الان واعلنت
الوكاله دوليه في وقت سابق انا المحطه
تعرضت الاثنين 10 هجرا في الفتره الماضيه
القصف الاخير امس ترى ادانه من الوكاله
الدوليه التي قالت ان مثل هذه الهجمات قد
تتسبب في حدوث كارثه كبرى وقد قال رافايل
جروسي مدير الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
ان الاخبار الوارده من محطه زابوريجيا
مزعجه جدا وهو امر
في المقبوله على الاطلاق وانايا كان من
يقف وراء ذلك يجب ان يتوقف على الفور
قائلا انهم او انتم تلعبون بالنار
هذه نشره مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
تويتر بانتظار حمله اقاله جديده للموظفين
بدء من اليوم
اهلا بكم من جديد بينما وضعت الهيئه
العليا المستقله للانتخابات في تونس اخر
لمسات اللوجستيه والتنظيميه لاجراء
الانتخابات التشريعيه تصاعد الخلاف
القانوني والسياسي بين مختلف الاطراف
المعنيه بالانتخابات في البلاد بين مؤيد
ورافض ما يؤكد واهميتها تركيبه البرلمان
المقبل في توضيح معالم المشهد السياسي
التونسي
هذه الاماكن المخصصه لتعليق قائمه
المترشحين للانتخابات التشريعيه باتت
جاهزه بمجرد انطلاق الحمله الانتخابيه
لاستقبال برامج المراهمين على اخذ مقاعد
في البرلمان القادم هي كما الفضاءات
العامه هيئه الانتخابات وضعت اخر لمسات
وفق الرزنامه المحدده سلفا الامر قد يبدو
عاديا الى هنا لكن خصوصيه هذا الاستحقاق
التشريعي وتابعه الاستثنائيه جعل الساعين
الى افشاله لا يترددون في انتاج كل السبل
ومنها تحرك الشارع والتوجه الى دوائر
خارجيه المعارضه التي بقيت تقريبا ولا
السنه كامله وهي تجتهد وتعمل وتقوم بكل ما
من شانه ان يسقط هذا المشروع الذي تجى
اليه رئيس قيس سعيد تبين فشلها وتبين ان
عاجزه من ان تحرك الشارع في تونس واعتقد
ان اهتمامات تونسيه بالفعل هي سياسيه ولكن
كذلك اقتصاديه ومعي الصراع يحتضم اذا بين
مؤيد ورافض ومقاطع واخرين مطالبين
بالتاجيل الكل يبسط حججه واسبابه لكن
الشارع المنشغله بواقعه الاقتصادي صعب
والاجتماعيه المترديه له راي اخر
تشوف الوضع في تونس
في عهد العشريه السوداء لا حقيقه ما بوجه
جديد بوجه همم ناس فهم الطرح بالقديده
قد تبلغ الاربعين بالمئه من مجموع
الناخبين في مناخ سياسيا وانتخابيا فارق
منذ اعلان الاجراءات الاستثنائيه في
البلاد
اللوجستيه البشريه لاجراء الاستحقاق
التشريعيه يتواصلوا الجدل حول شروط اجراء
الانتخابات من حيث النزاهه والشفافيه بين
مؤيد ورافيدا لتركيز الجمهوريه الجديده
وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
الى اليمن حيث تعاني العشرات من ضحايا
الالغام من نسائي تعز من الاعاقه جراء
باتري اطرافهن بعبوه والغام المليشيات
الحوثيه
ويعجزنا اولئك النسوه عن ممارسه حياتهن
بشكل طبيعي
في محافظه تعز
احرمني من كل شيء
اليوم الذي استعدت فيه الشابه دليله لتكون
العروس بيوم في تاريخها لقد مدير القدم
بلغم حوثي وعدل العريس عن قرار الزواج
قرار تقول الفتى حال حياتها الى جحيم كثير
انا معاقه 300 الان احنا مش رادين بيوتنا
مشردين من موانا
[موسيقى]
جبنا
ماشي هذيك دقايق اللقمه الاول به
اللقطه الثانيه لقيته عند اللقمه الثانيه
معور الرجل السلام معود
المهم كلهم اعاقه
سوسن تختزل بؤس الحياه لاكثر من 360 امراه
يمنيه في تعز اصبنا بعبوات والغام
المليشيات ثمن نساء منهن في منطقه الشقب
وحدها جنوبي المدينه
[موسيقى]
الى الاحياء لاسيما النساء والاطفال
فالمنازل في قرى الشرقيه يقول الاهالي من
صفات بعبوات المليشيات اما عقاراتهم
وممتلكاتهم صارت منهوبه بايدي قيادات
الحوثيه على مدى ثمانيه اعوام من
الحربيه انتهاكات الجسيمه بحق المدنيين
الى الاحياء السكنيه
في منطقه الشقب جنوبي تعز بعضها كانت
بالالغام والعبوات الناسفه وبعضها رميا
بالرصاص هل سعيد العربي تعز
[موسيقى]
ينتظر العاملون في تويتر موجوده تسريحات
جديده اليوم وذلك بعد استقالات جماعيه
شهيده الشركه يوم الخميس الماضي
التي ينوي مالك تويتر الجديد الى مصر
عليها ستؤثر على الموظفين المشاركين في
المبيعات والشركات وكان ماسك اصدر انذار
نهائيا للموظفين ان البقاء مع زياده ساعات
العمل او الاستقاله مع مكافاه نهايه
الخدمه
لثلاثه اشهر
افاده مركز ورصد الزلازل الاوروبيه
المتوسطين بان هذا ارضيه بقوه 5.4 درجات
ضربت جزيره كريتريت اليونانيه واضاف
المركزنا زلزله وقع على عمق 80 كم في حين
شعر سكان القاهره وبعض المدن المصريه
الساحليه بالهزه
اعربت وزيره خارجيه كوريا الشماليه عن
اسافيها الشديد لتمديد الامين العام للامم
المتحده
وكاله الانباء الرسميه ان موقف الامين
العام للامم المتحده موقف مؤسف للغايه
وانه ابتعد عن اهداف ميثاق الامم المتحده
ومبادئه وعن مهمته المتمثله في الحفاظ على
الحياه والموضوعيه والانصاف في جميع
الامور بحسب البيان الكوري الشمالي
في كازاخستان وعيدا انتخاب الرئيس
المنتهيه ولايته قاسم جمارك توكاياف اسر
انتخابات مبكرا وقد اثرت ثلاثه استطلاعات
وكاياف بحصوله على نحو
85% من الاصوات وفدت تقديرات الاوليه
للجنه الانتخابيه بان نسبه المشاركه في
الجمهوريه السوفياتيه السابقه بلغ 69.43%
الا مشاهدينا الى اخبار الرياضه مع الزميل
عبد الله درويش
[موسيقى]
خسر منتخب قطر المضيف الى مبارياته في كاس
العالم امام مالك ودور بهدفين دون رد في
افتتاح البطوله على ملعب البيت
فالنسيا افتتحت تسجيل لبلاده من ركله جزاء
بعد مرور ربع ساعه على البدايه قبل ان
يعود اللاعب نفسه ويضيف الهدف الثاني في
الدقيقه الحاديه والثلاثين من ضربه راسيه
باسم على اول ثنائيه شخصيه في هذه البطوله
ليصبح رابع لاعب يحرز هدفين في المباراه
الافتتاحيه في اخر خمس نسخ من البطوله بعد
مرور اسلاك لوزه في 2006 ونيمار في 2014
ودينيس 2018 كما باتت قطر اولا منتخب
المضيق يخسر مباراته الافتتاحيه في
البطوله الاكوادور وضعت في رصيدها ثلاث
نقاط في الصداقه بانتظار المباراه الثانيه
عن هذه المجموعه والتي تجمع هولندا وتلعب
قطر ضد السنغال في المباراه المقبله يوم
الجمعه
[تصفيق]
وقت التواصل الاثنين منافسات كاس العالم
باقامه ثلاث مباريات عن المجموعه الاولى
تلتقي هولندا مع السنغال في استاد الثمامه
افتتحوا منتخب وينجلترا مواجهات المجموعه
الثانيه بلقاء ايران في استاد خليفه
الدوري وضمن المجموعه نفسها يشهد ملعب
احمد بن علي مواجهه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه امام المنتخب الويلزي
تشارلي
بطوله لا تنسى لقد اخذناهم في رحله رائعه
في اخر بطولتين الى الناس نريد ان نعلمكم
ان بلادنا تمر ايضا لمرحله صعبه وليس نفس
الشيء مثل بعض البلدان الاخرى حول العالم
في الوقت الحالي لذلك نريدهم ان يستمتعوا
بكره القدم الخاصه بها وان يخوضوا رحله مع
فريق يجلب لهم بعضا من السعاده الحقيقيه
البارت
هدفنا ان نكون حاضرين في المباراه وان
نثبت وجودنا في كل لحظه من لحظاتها بروح
عاليه والقتاليه على كل لعبه حتى اخر
دقيقه من عمر اللقاء وان نلعب بعقليه
الفوز فقط وهذا ما ننويه خلال المباراه
انجلترا وفي كل مباراه نلعبها خلال هذه
البطوله
امريكا في المجموعه الثانيه ويل سعوده
للظهور في كاس العالم بعد 64 عاما من
المشاركه الاولى ويعول الوينسيون على
قائدهم ونجمهم المخضرم غاريث بيل الذي
حاسم له التاهل بعد ما سجل هدفين من اصل
ثلاثه خلال مباراته الملحقه امام النمس
كما سيعتمد المدرب روبرت بيتش على لاعب خط
الوسط المخضرم راسي وعدد من العناصر
البارزه امثال المدافع
كذلك استدعى بيج لاعب خط الوسط جوهان سيتي
رغم الشقوق التي حامد حول امكانيه مشاركه
في البطوله بعدما تعرض لاصابه في الفخذ في
سبتمبر
قل يا ايه
[موسيقى]
عندما تشاهد انجلترا والولا
يات المتحدهما للتاهل عن هذه المجموعه
تفوقي على منتخبنا وكذلك ايران ولكننا
قدمنا مباريات قويه امام بلجيكا وهولندا
في دوري الامم ونستطيع تكرار ذلك نحن فريق
جديد في هذه البطوله واربما نفجر بعض
المفاجات حيث لا نواجه اي ضغوطات نريد ان
نستمتع بالمشاركه ولكننا سننافس ونقدم كل
ما لدينا
اعتقد اننا ممتنون جدا لاي نوع من الدعم
يصلنا من الوطن كاس العالم شيء المميز
بالنسبه لنا واشعر انه الشيء الاول الذي
سيشاهده الامريكيون عندما يتعلق الامر
بكره القدم لذلك نحن متحمسون حقا وممتنون
لاي نوع من الدعم الذي يمكننا الحصول عليه
وسنقدم كل ما لدينا ونمل ان نجعل الجميع
في الوطن فخوره
نهايه عوده الاستكمال ما تبقى من هذه
النشره
[موسيقى]
نشره لم يبقى الى التذكير بابرز ما جاء
فيها
صاروخ عفوا ايراني العراق
تظاهرات ليليه في مدن ايرانيه وواشنطن
تتواعد بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن قمع
المتظاهرين
الوكاله الذريات تجرى تقييم لاضرار محطه
زابوريجيا وقصف المدفعي الروسي المكثف
لشرق اوكرانيا
اليكم بعد دقائق في نشره اخرى
[تصفيق]